I'm here with one of my favorites, Roy Wood Jr.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
And we were just talking in the break about what we're
watching on TV, and so we're gonna talk a little TV.
All right, the Hollywood reporter says that Emily in Paris
has just been picked up for not one, but two more seasons
by Netflix, and I got to tell you, I produced a show
on Netflix called Santa Clarita diet,
I know how that studio functions,
and this is a big deal for them to grant
two seasons to something.
So it's obviously going gangbusters.
I'm so happy for them.
And I got to say, I binged the second season in one day.
What are you currently watching, Roy?
What are you binging?
What should we all be watching?
I am finally at a point with regards to just my workload
where I can actually plug back in to stuff that's on TV.
So I'm just, I'm devouring sitcoms right now.
Grand Crew on NBC I love, and Abbott Elementary on ABC,
I think they're two of the best shows out right now.
They're saying Grand Crew is like the new Friends.
Yeah, I like Grand Crew 'cause it's just black people
just hanging out and being black and existing
and paying bills and dating and it's not slavery
every two lines.
It's like, we know the stresses of being a minority,
but also it's dope to just see people just existing in their
world and just dealing with everyday, dating and the mundane
all the way to the extreme.
And is there any standup because I have been watching
your special that's coming out and I'm freaking out.
I love the filler talk, I love when you're saying
about the one cast member who has to take one for the team
to tell historical movies.
I was just eating it up, I love it so much.
So obviously we're all gonna watch your show and that's
gonna go in the little yellow book as a suggestion,
which is our personal curation of everything
we think you should get, watch, check out, buy,
have in your life to make it better.
But is there any comedy that you think
we should look out for?
There are two standup comedians that just had a Netflix
specials drop that I thought were really funny.
Well, there was Naomi, there was Brian Simpson
and Janelle James.
Janelle James plays the principal on Abbott elementary.
So like, just very, very funny stand ups,
but if you go watch the stand-ups on Netflix,
there's a lot of great comedians on there right now.
You know, when you look at where we are as a country,
you know, like, let's take Bob Saget.
Yes.
When you look at the stretch of work that he did
for decades, and it's easy to forget
just how much someone delivering a laugh to you
on a weekly basis, time and time again,
all the way from America's funniest home videos,
all the way to Full House.
To be able to do that and impact people, you know,
it's a gift and an honor, and the people who do it well,
you know, they should always be celebrated.
I think that's why they've always been my heroes.
And Bob Saget was an incredible person.
I hung out with him one night.
I'll never forget it.
It was at this hotel in Hollywood,
and I was sitting with him and Joe Cocker and we were
throwing some drinks back and hanging out.
And I remember laughing because he talked dirty
and said swear words, and I had only, you know,
I'd been watching him on Full House and I was like,
"Oh, this is so cool.
I can talk the way I talk in front of him"
And he was just so lovely and real and funny and cool.
And when you see this outpour, even his last tweets
were so gracious to people,
and comedians do an incredible service to humanity,
and they should be seen as that.
Yeah, I just think it's important to remember
that every comedian is just trying to heal you
while healing himself.
Yes, exactly.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Exactly.
Well, on that note, I think, you know,
maybe all of us could tell each other a joke,
or if somebody you know is going through it,
do everything you can to lighten their load,
make them laugh and be appreciative of all the comedians
out there who are brave enough to do that for us.
(crowd cheers)
(applause)
Including Roy Wood Jr.
Thank you so much for coming to this desk today,
it is an honor.
Don't forget to check out Roy's brand new comedy special,
Imperfect Messenger coming to paramount plus
on January 19th.
I've seen it, I love it, you're gonna love it too.
(upbeat music)